what does regulation do you guys know
this dealing with the insurance stuff
and the annuity stuff and the financial
planning stuff you said legitimacy no
doubt it gives trust into the
marketplace and it gives credibility So
Bad actors and people who are basically
taking advantage of people sorry you're
not going to be able to scam as many
people with whatever you're doing
there's going to be some regulation
there and overregulation is I think what
people have a problem with but laying
down regulation the the law of the land
so to speak the the the the road map to
how to basically trade this type of
asset class I think overall is going to
be a good thing and I think it'll help
legitimize the good actors in The crypto
space